hello everyone and welcome to what
appears to be the most eventful round of
defeating candidates tournament 2022
it's already
versus richard rapport uh neither of
them are having the tournament they were
hoping for but rapport still having a
bit of a better one he did lose the game
to nippon ish but he did beat uh young
shisht of duda in the previous round
whereas alireza uh only lost two games
and all the other uh were drawn he lost
to fabiana carwana and uh yanni pognishi
as nepo pretty much defeated everyone in
this tournament uh and now both of them
would very much enjoy a win in this game
uh so let's see what happened alireza
has the white pieces uh and he opens
with pawn to e4 we have e5 by rapport
knight to f3 knight to c6 and the bishop
to b5 and again we have the berlin
defense knight to f6 and i'm not even
gonna say it we have d3 uh and the
bishop to c5 and here all it is just
castles in the game uh that we've
discussed uh or rather in the line that
we've discussed in the previous video uh
where um you had rajabo and nakamura
where they each played against each
other either c3 or knight b to d2 those
are all very popular moves but here we
have just castles
knight to d for now going for this uh
rarish move now just attacking the
bishop and we have a trade knight
captures bishop captures and pawn to c3
chasing away the bishop bishop to b6 and
now knight to a3 this is how all it is
it develops the knight c6 chasing away
the bishop bishop a for d6 and the
bishop
b3 all been played before nothing
spectacular here queen to e7 and now
knight to c for putting pressure on the
bishop here and there is agai there is
one game that reached this exact same
position between uh karjakin and david
from the 2017 or rather from the 2019
world blitz championship were just
bishop to c7 was played and vedic
defeated karjakin uh with this move but
here instead of moving the bishop we
have uh just bishop to g for attacking
the queen here and it is now as of move
11 that we have a completely new game so
queen to e1 all there is the sidesteps
this and now bishop to c5 keeping the
bishop on this diagonal not shifting it
over to c7
we have king to h1 getting away from
this diagonal you want to be able to
push f4 and now a5 bit upward we have f4
a4 attacking the bishop and the bishop
to c2 we have pawn to b5 and now e and
not just f captures on e5 so we don't
have time for this because e captures an
f6 d captures and now all it is a place
knight captures an e5 it's not a peace
sacrifice you will win it back after d4
is played uh but still yeah it um
makes it a bit difficult for a rapper to
castle the king to safety as you'll see
so queen captures on e5 and now the
immediate d4 you have to win the bishop
back but it also means destroying your
own center bishop capture c captures and
queen captures on d4 and here we have
the amazing bishop to e3 where alireza
dares rapper to capture on b2 now the
problem with uh sacha there is that um
it is the absolute strongest move
recommended by the engine just capturing
the pawn on b2 uh but it's also it also
means that your king will stay in the
center of the board for quite some time
so you have to weigh your options here
but it's not it's not much better
if you just move the queen we're going
to keep harassing you for example queen
e5 bishop f4 now you've just improved
white's position and the there is still
there only not not as good as it as it
was a move ago so here rapper accepts
the challenge he plays queen captures on
b2 and now we have queen to f2 a very
very tricky uh tricky idea because now
if rapper just castles if you could
castle of course that'd be great you
just grabbed some material bishop d4 and
basically you resigned this after we
moved the queen we're gonna play queen
h4 now we're attacking the bishop or
rather threatening bishop captures queen
captures here if the pawn moves then
we're also attacking h7 so there are so
many threats here yeah you don't even
have to play it properly most likely so
instead after queen to f2 bishop back to
e6 era continues in the strongest
possible way and now bishop to d4 this
is how we're still keeping the black
king in the center of the board queen to
b4 and now bishop to c5 and the black
king is no longer leaving the
uh the center of the board so it's a
it's a brave way to play but uh i don't
know i it'd be it'd be very difficult to
to talk me into doing something like
this you know against someone or someone
of my own skill i would prefer you know
i keep the pawn i just want to have my
king nicely castle or if for example if
you knew the line extremely well then of
course you you can play it
but okay queen to c3 and now rook ate
the c1 again
making it a bit of a problem uh
to castle because how do you actually
castle here not king said of course king
said castling is impossible due to the
bishop but if you cancel queenside then
there are many many tactics here all it
is i can just play something like bishop
a7 now you prepare discoveries here it's
uh
uh
terrible position for black queen can
come to b6 it's it's just super ugly for
example queen e5 you can even play
bishop b3 such tricky moves are also
possible and if you capture queen b6 now
threatening queen captures and c6 good
luck defending this so instead rook the
d8 by rapport again the absolute
strongest move recommended by the engine
and now bishop b1 opening up an attack
towards the queen queen e5 and now
alireza goes queen to h4
so what uh what can rapper do he can't
move the king and it's uh well it's a
very very tricky position basically what
you want to do is improve the position a
little bit with some like rook to d7 uh
and then start the g5 attack the queen
put the rook on g8 or maybe just g5 h5g
for star start your attack and keep the
king in the center of the board however
after bishop to c4 there is one move
that alireza can play that really just
uh well
that gives
him a winning position and it's uh it's
a tough one to accept but it definitely
is in the position so feel free to pause
the video and win this game for alireza
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
tricky idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is rook
to f5 that's the move and this is as
josh waitskin would say the space left
behind the bishop was on e6 guarding the
square when he played bishop to c4
attacking the rook on f1 the f5 square
became available for the white rook and
of course alireza played it we even have
a nice photo before this moment uh
whoops that's not the one that i'm
talking about um my bad uh just give me
one second uh this is the one from the
previous video but this is the one that
i'm talking about so you can see uh
that's the position on the board and
rook to f5 can be played here uh and
that is of course what all it is a plate
we can enjoy the the photo for for a few
seconds as usual but um you know nothing
out of the ordinary here so we can focus
on the game
so
yeah but also you know it's important to
notice that rapport is not wearing his
salmon shirt so that could also be uh
you know you know a problem for him uh
but okay queen to b2 now getting the
queen out of harm's way and now comes
rook to g1 rook to e1 also is very
strong uh for some reason already that
plays rook to g1 but still it's
incredibly difficult to to make moves
for
uh for rapport here he plays bishop back
to e6 attacks the rook now queen to g3
offering the rook for some uh queen
captures and g7 action basically if
bishop captures pawn captures uh rook to
e1 will just be deadly with the bishop
controlling this diagonal so you could
play some like queen d2 but then we
capture on g7 attack the rook attack of
the night and of course black resigns so
here knight back to d7 attacking the
bishop and all it is just plays bishop
to d6 so now at some point of course
we're going to also play e5 and you are
asking are you maybe interested in the
rook now but still capturing the rook
now uh just he captures an f5 and your
position did not improve still the same
threats are are in the position so uh
what you could do here is just go back
knight to f6 try and attack the bishop
this way but even though this is clever
it would not be enough alireza can just
attack the queen here and after queen d4
bishop back to c5 now the bishop is safe
on a guarded square and here even after
knight captures an e4 attacking all it
is a screen we can just trade bishop
captures queen captures and now rook e5
uh that's a game for example queen g6
offers a queen trade queen to c3 and you
don't have a move the other rook is also
coming into the game and there's no move
you can make here with black so it's
just a terrible terrible so after bishop
to d6 queen to d4 was played instead and
now we have rook f back to f1 with the
idea that if the knight moves so we can
attack the bishop with the rook and the
queen we just play rook to d1 and that
will also be winning so here rapper says
all right i have to start my king side
expansion h5 now comes e5 now the bishop
is uh on d6 for for the rest of the game
basically queen to g for offering a
queen trade just queen to e3
uh we have h4 h3 and now queen to h5
but it doesn't really do all that much
for upper bishop to e4 and now we are
going after the base of the pawn chain
and there is no good way for you to
defend this uh queen to h6 and upward
offers a queen trade but now queen to f3
uh we have f6 now but now algorithm just
starts gobbling up the pawns and there's
no way to prevent this bishop captures
on c6 king to f7 we have bishop captures
and b5 queen to h5 now offering a trade
but still queen e4 knight captures an e5
and now uh okay this knight captures on
e5 comes with a little trick from
rapport because if bishop captures um
yes there's all this uh f file action
here uh but there is maybe rook d5
attacking the bishop and the bishop on
b5 so it's still winning for white
battalion doesn't want to mess around
with this he just moves the bishop with
tempo now you don't you will not have
this rook to d5 trick and after the
queen moved he just played bishop
captures on e5 and he was in this
position on 41 after reaching time
control that richard rapport resigned
the game and alireza gets his first
victory in the classical uh um
in the feeder candidates tournament uh
2022 or or rather his first victory ever
in a feed a candidate's tournament here
you resign because well you're down a
piece and you don't have any
compensation for it of course you can't
capture back because the f pawn is
pinned so that would be out of the
question
so basically there's no move black can
make here so really really uh fine one
it really seems like uh these round nine
games are are
nowhere near the the the quality of
round eight games as they are you know
so so quick uh the you know players just
uh fall apart uh but i guess that's why
uh probably because
they they got tired and maybe from
playing all of those exhausting games in
round eight but uh you know it's hard to
say definitely so much happening in
round nine and we still haven't finished
with everything that that happened so
we're gonna discuss it a bit more and
then we are going to show the standing
so expect
at least one more game uh so yeah that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed it very
nice for alireza for getting his first
victory but tough for a rapport uh who
didn't manage to get uh maybe uh you
know either another win or a draw but
that's how the candidates tournament
works uh so yeah once again hope you
guys enjoyed it i would like to thank uh
stephen mcneill beat outbid is the one
daniel schmidt ultimate poker coaching
and mohamed el al-saban for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
candidates until it finishes uh so thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day